enough all right we must talk about the
most important story of our generation
Amber Heard pooped on Johnny Depp's bed
why why would she do it well you know
thick in the head as the world burns
down around us perhaps it's fun and
important to kind of get a good relaxing
story about some celebrity female and a
feud of a battle of allegations and
abuse and the latest story that well the
real story is that the petition to
remove Amber Heard from Aquaman 2 has
almost reached 400,000 signatures I
agree
get her out of there 300 thousand and
one but you know what's my signature
going on as soon as I find how to do
this this was a tough call for me right
the abuse allegations were serious and
as soon as I heard and saw that audio I
was like get her out get her out but
then when I heard she pooped on Johnny
Depp's bed I was like bring her back
totally kidding so let's see let's let's
read the story do you have some sort of
fetish I don't know about it's the
family guy joke where they're at the
police auction and they're like like the
underwear of a prostitute okay and he's
quagmire goes $40 and he was like and
when he was he was like I came or what
he said but he's like oh yeah he's like
she soiled herself and we caught her and
he goes $45 and it's like and she had
some STDs and he goes $40 like he goes
back now he still wants some or
something like that that's a joke gross
the petition to get Amber Heard removed
as Mira from Aquaman 2 is getting very
close to reaching 400 K signatures
unchanged at org over the past few weeks
there's been a noticeable surge the
number of people signing this petition I
remember when the petition hadn't passed
100 K and there was a huge jump in the
number of people signing it I think the
main reason why people have felt so
strongly that heard should should play
mere at NACA Man 2 is all the evidence
that's come that that she should have
come out against her in the past few
weeks
Amber Heard had previously claims she
was the victim of domestic abuse while
she was married to Johnny Depp she went
on in public with bruises on her face
and she claimed that he was a he was
abused during their time together
oh no but this is poorly written yeah
what is not the first time they've there
have been recordings leaked of the two
of them and they make it quite clear who
was abusing who there have been court
documents which paint a very bad picture
for the Aquaman actress she reporter
here we go here we go drum roll please
she reportedly defecated on Johnny
Depp's bed her heard cut his finger into
she also threw a tin of paint at his
face wait that she actually did cut his
finger into yeah I figured that finger
off cuz someone made a super chat about
that I didn't know she actually cut him
now I got to say I don't this is real
did she what is going on why what is
wrong with her I don't know if I believe
this story about her pooping on the bed
it said reportedly right we don't know
the truth pooped on his bed well hold on
we got this story yeah cut and like we
need F could say yeah she cut me is
there anything in this we have another
story where Johnny Depp fans say Amber
Heard deserves jail after resurfaced
video shows actor with prominent bruise
the clip which has been uploaded on
Twitter with the hashtag justice for
Johnny Depp was of Depp's guest
appearance on the Graham Norton Show in
November 2015 Oh interesting so there's
evidence of this in like mainstream TV
shows hmm fans of Johnny Depp claimed to
have uncovered further proof the actor
was physically abused by Amber Heard in
a video where he is seemingly sporting a
bruise under his eye during a television
interview the clip which was uploaded on
Twitter we yeah we saw that with the
Graham Norton Show in it he's talking
about some of the quirky characters he's
played over the years and the creative
process behind some alongside Sherlock
and Avengers star Benedict Cumberbatch
the pair had appeared together to
discuss their biological crime drama
film black mass as Norton talks to about
his roles the camera zooms into his left
eye where he has a prominent bruise
before cutting to a snap of Captain Jack
Sparrow
while there is no indication from the
actors end that he had been injured
during the interview his fans have
insisted that he was while blaming Amber
Heard and called for him to be
reinstated into the pipes of the
Caribbean franchise hear hear yes I'm
well yeah but are they really making
more of those movies yeah
and people watch it I guess I mean I'm
not necessarily saying like man people
are beating stories to death over and
over it's like let's make some new
stories pirates of the you know the West
Indies yes yeah I ran thing but I'll go
see it only because I'm the youngest
like boy I won't see Aquaman - if she's
in it I agree I won't do it
nope I'm not gonna do it yep for me it's
about the double standards like you have
this big me - movement yeah we nobody
know but no sane person likes domestic
abuse in any direction yeah but if and
so what's what's really annoying to me
is that she got away with it for as long
as she did mmm like Johnny got fired
from Pirates of the Caribbean over this
yep he's the victim get her out of there
man exactly you know I don't I don't
normally like - well it's tough
sometimes there are issues where I'm
like that's a red line for me I won't
support this company okay I've said in
the past that if a company ever tries to
get into like culture war issues I'm out
but I've kind of softened up on this
like there was something happened with
Hulu I think where they tweeted some
ridiculously stupid Halloween thing like
make sure not to we're culturally
appropriating costumes and I'm like shut
up you're you're a streaming service for
TV shows I mean your opinion on politics
yeah
so I cancelled it I was like count me
out if you want to get political I don't
want to do anything with your service
but then I thought that was kind of like
snowflake in a sense my main point was I
don't want to be involved but then I was
kind of like you know what if a company
is gonna do something I don't care what
the company's doing I don't care you
know
there's a difference between what
chick-fil-a does and who they donate to
behind the scenes and what a company
publicly announces they want or support
okay but ultimately like you know what I
just I'm not gonna care that much
however this is different this is this
is a woman who it's it's it's more
individual than it is about like what
companies do you know Amber Heard like
seriously like almost ruined Johnny
Depp's life over this yep I'm not a fan
I don't like that I don't like it if I
want justice for Johnny Depp yeah
exactly I mean you know my personal part
about it like I have a friend from high
school who had a girl
claimed that he raped her and then two
years later after he's been in prison
the whole time admitted that he never
did and she was just upset because he
broke up with her and she lied and she
she didn't go to jail or anything for
that he got out of prison and he was let
free and it's like sorry sorry we took
two of your years away because we just
instantly believe this girl yep and so
that's a that's a huge issue that was a
good friend of mine who lost two years
of his life because this girl was
believed simply no questions asked threw
him in prison for two years
it's like this kind of stuff really like
upsets me you know it's like I want you
know it's like I'm not saying I don't
believe women I'm saying find the
information that's true and and innocent
until proven guilty right I yes and and
what bothers me about all of this is
that the default is always it's always
it's always a weird cultural political
thing you know like with with the Joe
Biden thing going on right now I tweeted
something I tweeted something like you
know Joe Biden's been credibly accused
and Bernie and orsten you know and then
some anti-trump guy responded like uh
you you shouldn't trust her accusation
and I'm like why not believe all hashtag
believe all women yeah right that's what
we were told every step of the way like
it's time and start believing the women
what we did it with Johnny Depp and it
was fake news and we did it with you
know I'm having aa well yeah I knew and
that was mostly fake news to a bunch of
those people who accused Kevin I walked
there their accusations back or
apologized over canted outright so at
this point they've had a bad string of
luck with propping up people who turn to
be liars yeah like why choose the yeah
you'd have to pick Amber Heard and then
she gets exposes making this stuff up
basically yeah
and you know like pooping on someone's
bed muscle man one wasn't really that
good it was an okay movie I'd give it
like a six point two but you know what I
I don't remember from the film Amber
Heard I agree I don't know what she
doing it I don't remember her at all oh
she ate a flower I remember really cool
underwater fighting scenes and like huge
armies of fish which is dope yeah and
that's a big waves yeah I mean there's
some cool
parts in that movie but she was not in
it I want to see how come in - oh now
you want to see it I don't want to see
it with her in it I guess there it is I
would like to see the movie but I will
care significantly less about it if
she's in the movie I'll just feel like I
don't know it's gonna pull me out of the
movie I'm gonna be like there's that
girl that ruined Johnny Depp almost
almost well either way there's there she
is I am looking at Amber Heard not
whatever character she got in Aquaman -
I gotta be honest you know I'm not gonna
think that at all no when I watch that
and I see her on the screen I'm not
gonna be thinking at all about Johnny
Depp I'm gonna be imagining or pooping
on a bed oh I'm serious I'm not trying
to set it to be funny or like that this
has become the story somebody asked us
into super chat the other day and I'm
like that can't be but I've heard it's a
rumor I don't know reportedly someone
from Johnny Depp this is something he
says he's nobody said yeah found it he
says 2018 August 2018 he's talking about
how he found this little gift on their
bed that's the source well it's from
multiple difference so she did it so now
I'm gonna be watching her and there's
gonna be this epic battle scene and he's
gonna be like Meera come help and I'm
gonna see her and I'm gonna think it's
her just like wait if she's wearing like
a really thin or a tight suit right and
you think you're gonna like look at her
butt and be like no no there is she
thinks she's pooping no like in her suit
too much dude she's the poop lady now I
just Johnny Depp made her the poop lady
I just gave her and the first thing that
comes up petition remove Amber Heard
from Aquaman - yeah I gotta do it this
is the first thing so we got toilet girl
and we got poop lean on toilet girl yeah
the no toilet girl you know man look I
think everybody deserves second chances
if she came out and said you know what I
went through with Johnny Depp was a
mistake and I feel terrible about it I'm
so sorry to everybody in my fans I hope
Johnny can find it in his heart to
forgive me or whatever I'd be like what
do you say Johnny like bygones be
bygones we can move forward and give her
out a chance yeah look - Johnny and be
like what do you think right and then
I'd be like I don't believe her be like
it's not about that Johnny its if she
came out and owned up to the mistake she
made
mm-hm and apologized I'd be inclined to
say I'll go see your movie but she
didn't she came out and said Johnny Depp
did it he hit me he did this to me
yeah and then Johnny had to release the
recordings where she's like so what
you're a baby so what I hit you and I'm
like boom I'm a girl no one will believe
you exactly yeah that was it that line
right there's exactly why I won't go see
things exactly like see how many people
believe you yeah oh dude I'll tell you
what you want to know what I believe
I'll believe that I will not see your
movie yep not interested not interested
at all no but I but I'm definitely
interested automated so here's the
problem with Aquaman one it was it was
almost a really good movie but there was
a weird composition like things the
music hmm didn't fit like you know the
scene when uh when the manta guy is
dad's dying in the submarine yeah it's
like playing this dramatic music and
he's like fighting his way out right did
not work yeah that was a weird scene
actually I'm like I was a little it felt
a little much I think they didn't need
to there's some of the scenes in that
movie that were like my why didn't he
feel why it didn't made me feel anything
else exactly but they were really trying
they're pushing it yep that's what it
was but the visuals of that big undersea
battle was awesome the undersea
creatures you know what I really liked
about it when is it the brother I think
it's the brother the prince or whatever
yeah and he's like explaining why he's
going to war it actually makes a lot of
sense reason I was like oh man he he's
right like we as humans have been dumped
the ocean has been a dump for us we've
been like it's the oceans messed up the
whole the Elco systems like relearning
how to live right now so and his
argument is like they've just been
pooping on us like Amber Heard years yes
yes you know and I'd like to see the
movie can start and it literally starts
with him being like you know he walked
he's walking down the street and he's
like Oh Mira come with me and then she
walks to cross the street then a boss
just hits her and then she's out of the
movie she's gone and then as soon as he
says that then he's like his phone rings
oh man I better get this and these
leaves that's it she's gone no one says
anything else it's like we wrote her out
with the bus I mean do we really even
need to have anything couldn't it just
have the movie and just not have her in
it and just just that that's it just
done is interesting man I'm glad to see
that Johnny Depp's getting this kind of
support I mean there there are a lot of
you even you know like social justice II
like feminists who have come out and
support supporter this guy yeah I
respect it I wish that they would stop
just blanket believing anybody because I
don't care if you're a man woman
Christian Jewish never boom if you got
the proof you feel you bro so you know
what that when they say like believe all
women I'm like yes at face value and
then you investigate trust but verify
right so if you come to me and say this
happened I'll say I will take it
seriously and I will I will operate off
of the assumption that you are telling
me the truth yeah I will not go destroy
someone's life I will not arrest to them
we will go and gather evidence you know
if we can't prove it nothing happens
boom what they want on it but they want
to change the standards and this is what
happens so I'll tell you what you know I
probably people take advantage I
probably did not have gone and seen a
new Pirates movie but because of this it
definitely will yeah agreed
sure now I'm gonna be like the junk is
an incredible actor he's cool did some
really awesome movies outside of pirates
I mean pirates was it's fun yeah but as
far as like an act as acting goes he's
really good so I guess I can just uh you
know my final thought is I wish Johnny
Depp well in his career and I wish him
clean sheets yeah for sure
Oh divorced it probably will be more
likely yes I wish will come true yeah
clean sheets for Johnny Depp indeed we
should we should change the the hash tag
from justice - Johnny Depp - clean
sheets for Johnny Johnny
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the neck
episode
you